tant lui l'interview un parmi d'autres
j'ai déjà les réductions d'émissions
pardon j'avais 2007 émission une fois
d'ailleurs j'ai été très choquée c'est
j'avais presque envie de venir en
courant c'était quand il y avait un
philosophe parisien type closerie des
lilas qui s'appelait finkielkrault oui
c'est ça c'est un nom qui ressemble car
yvan et qui expliquait en gros que les
palestiniens est il cette étape
désespérée mais qu'ils avaient le
désespoir pas très poli puisqu'il a
laissé faire sauter chez les gens j'ai
trouvé ça totalement indécent des vidéos
tellement grossier et malvoyants qu'il a
réussi à faire pleurer
la délicieuse du web binoche moi je vous
soumets m'a profondément choqué j'avais
parce qu'on visite en bretagne de
prendre la voiture et d'intervenir sur
le plateau et dire voilà parce que quand
on en arrive à se faire sauter avec des
cartouches dîner mais c'est qu'on est
franchement des intérêts voilà il n'y a
pas de politesse ou pas avoir des
espoirs donc
heureusement que t'as pas la télé la
bagnole faire 500 banques pour mettre un
bon pays fin mais quelle connerie ouais
imaginons serait pas trop regarder
dehors
un parmi d'autres donc si vous étiez un
des sept péchés capitaux vous seriez
lequel la luxure je ferai plus souvent
la télévision
parce que si vous étiez à les dix
commandements tu ne tueras point comme
ça je n'hésiterai pas un des sept nains
simple est comme ça je pourrais me
présenter à la campagne présidentielle
est méritée il ya du gras chez toi aussi
si vous étiez en décembre elle maintient
le dernier le 101e pour être chouchou
est une des sept merveilles du monde
les jardins suspendus de babylone qui
aujourd'hui se trouve à bagdad comme ça
je serai du jardinage avec interdiction
pour les chars de marché sur la pelouse
ça bravo
si vous étiez un des cinq sens l'odorat
pour m'autodétruire lors de la promotion
de films au vous étiez 1,17 à nos
cinémas pour apprendre quelques trucs un
des quatre points cardinaux le sud pour
pouvoir perdre le nord en permanence en
bravo mais qu'est-ce que vous étiez à
les trois mousquetaires d'artagnan pour
piquer les ferrer la reine plutôt que de
lui rendre à cette union est un des sept
mercenaires du brenner pour avoir une
coupe de cheveux toujours à la mode
vous étiez à l'air du temps qu est l'un
des 12 travaux d'hercule les écuries
d'augias on voit passer le fleuve par
matignon l'elysée l'assemblée nationale
la balle si vous étiez à les 31 jours du
mois le premier pendant les vacances et
dernier pendant que ce travail bravo
si vous étiez à 17 jours de la semaine
le lundi parce que tout est encore
possible et un des cinq continents
l'afrique pour me venger
merci